moi je rêvais d'une petite vie
tranquille je pensais qu'ils allaient
faire un peu de politique et ensuite
fermé mais juge
et puis sa peau était ça mais j'ai très
fier le scénario n'a pas été le même en
effet c'est plutôt après 40 ans de vie
politique aux côtés de son homme qu'elle
est une chrétiens s'apprête à tourner la
page en l'an 2000 vous auriez peut-être
aimé qu'il qu'il accroche ses patins
comme on dit ce que ce manque dans l'eau
qu'il s'apprête à terminer les deux
trous comme celui là vraiment je les
trouvais ça m'a surpris mais j'étais
tellement contente après il ya eu
tellement de belles majorité puis au
fait ya pas si kyoto il a fait de
grandes choses encore dans le dernier
mandat
mais je m'y attendais pas mais quand
parce qu'on avait bâti notre maison
aussi mais ça fait rien on a tous les
donneurs beaucoup d'énergie pour tous
les deux parce qu'elle est chrétien n'a
jamais été mise de côté dans la vie du
premier ministre on a toujours été une
équipe
alors maintenant qu'il est premier
ministre souvent je fais partie des
discussions
je lis ces discours je l'aide dans ses
discours
c'est comme si j'étais une assistance et
j'aime beaucoup ce
la première dame a mis aussi beaucoup
d'efforts pour conserver la flamme dans
son couple pas de raison pour qu'on
s'entende pas il faut se parler
le fait aussi que gt5 un seul shopping
en avait toujours à devoir j'attends
produit depuis longtemps c'est toujours
été comme ça février 2004
aline chrétien n'attendra plus le p'tit
gars de shawinigan va rentrer à la
maison
une nouvelle vie qui marquera la fin de
toute une époque
j'ai un peu mélancolique là depuis
quelques temps là je vois tous les gens
puis je me dis mon dieu
le personnel de la résidence les gardes
du corps
je vais manquer tout cela mais par
contre moi je suis une personne qui je
m'ajuste très facilement et puis je suis
en train de me ranger pas que la coupure
soit trop grave
et puis je suis certaine qu'on va faire
une belle vie parce qu'on attend
moi j'attends ça depuis très longtemps
caroline brochure est au canada
trois rivières